i was very shocked and i was obviously
devastated i felt like my heart just
sank to the bottom of my
stomach cheerleading is the only thing
that could get my mind off of everything
else
we see so many ups and downs this season
and we see you
get the news that frankly shocked the
world about jerry how
emotional how devastating was that for
you i would say that was the by far
most devastating thing that happened it
was very hard the jerry that i knew is
the jury that you guys saw and it was
the you know the one that was lifting
people up when they were down it was the
positive one that was always making you
smile and laugh and even on your worst
days you know like him just being there
and smiling it was like that was the
jury that i knew so when i got the news
i was very shocked and i was obviously
devastated i felt like my heart just
sank to the bottom of my stomach it was
a very hard time for sure you talk a
little bit in the episodes about how you
don't feel you can turn your back on him
because this was a person who was like
family to you where do you stand on that
now and have you spoken to jerry at all
what i said then is exactly how i feel
to this day like my feelings will never
change on that and i stand very strongly
in what i said um just because obviously
do i support the things that happen
absolutely not but i do think that he is
always going to have a place in my heart
that i feel will never just go away
because that was like my family and just
the whole situation i feel it's very sad
and obviously cheerleading should be a
safe place for
everyone it should be it should be a
safe place so it's more like a
love the sinner hate the sin type of
situation
and i
you know that love doesn't just go away
but i obviously do not condone
anything that happened but his case is
still open so i'm being very
you know i'm just kind of like sitting
back hoping for
like the best what would the best be for
you the best would be for hopefully the
allegations to
not be true and obviously no one's gonna
know that until his case is dealt with
in court so were you all aware that in
season two his alleged victims are
interviewed and they are part of season
two
no i do not
know that
and uh uh yeah i did not know that but
i my heart goes out to anybody
that was affected and anyone that was in
that situation and
obviously cheerleading should be a safe
place for everyone will you watch all
the episodes and and
how do you think that will feel for you
to watch and to hear from them there's
pretty much a whole episode devoted to
jerry it seems like he filmed a lot with
you guys but he's not in much and then
there's a whole episode sort of devoted
to everything where his alleged victims
speak out
obviously i haven't watched the show for
myself and i
you know i'm not really sure if i'm
going to be able to watch it because it
was a very emotional time for
me personally so i'm not really sure how
i'm gonna react i'm just gonna really
try to look at the positive things in
the show because i know that there are a
lot of good things in the show and i
know that it's showcasing mainly like
what we do so i really want i want to
focus on that more so because there were
a lot of really good things out of that
season monica mentions that jerry wrote
her a letter and i just talked to morgan
and she said she's spoken to him a
little bit have you spoken to jerry at
all have you guys been in touch yeah i
will kee i keep in touch with him also
and i write him basically the same way
monica does i'll hear from him every
once in a while there's just talk about
the safety of cheerleaders what if
anything do you think needs to change in
the way that the regulations are the way
the industry's set up for cheerleaders
or do you think things are good
i definitely do think that as a whole
like cheerleading there are things that
need to be fixed i think that
you know there are situations
like
this one that happen
a lot more often than people even
realize in cheerleading and i think that
overall yes like we could do a much
better job of keeping cheerleading
safe and basically
just a bringing light to situations
because i feel like there are a lot of
things that happen that are not brought
to light and
i think that
yes there are things that need to be
discussed and i think there are things
that need to be brought to light for
sure
[Music]